hello everyone and welcome to another
spectacular game from the 37th European
Club cup 2022. it's vishwanathan versus
and as uh gookish and the Arjun
education are trying very hard to
overtake Vichy as the number one uh
Indian player on the on the world uh
rating list uh it's uh we're always very
enjoyable to see what Anand has to say
about that so let's check it out it's
it's quite a beautiful game you guys
will enjoy it uh there's a lot of theory
in the first like 20 moves but as usual
we will skip most of it so Anand uh has
the white pieces and he opens with E4 we
have E5 Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and
Bishop to B5 going for the URI Lopez
with a six morphe defense Bishop to A4
and Knight to F6 uh so nothing nothing
out of the ordinary here castles offers
D for Pawn this is all very standard
Knight captures and pawn to D for now we
have B5 challenging the bishop Bishop to
B3 and now Pawn to D5 and now just the D
captors on E5 grabbing that pawn bishop
to E6 and now as the pawn is defended
Pawn to C3
the bishop might come under attack so
you want to have a retreat Square for
the bishop so here we have Bishop to E7
Knight B to D2 and now Knight to C5 uh
Shifting the attack towards the bishop
Bishop back to C2 and then now Pawn to
D4 now as the queen is no longer
guarding the D4 Pawn uh which he just
goes back Knight to B3 now attacking the
D4 Pawn with everything he has and now
comes Pawn to D3 again this is all very
very standard stuff in this line of the
real Lopez uh point is that two moves
can be played here Knight captures and
C5 can be played but it's not a very
serious attempt for white because if you
capture first black captures on C2
attacks your queen and now you have to
trade Queens for example Queen captures
Rook captures you will miss a black
spawn structure but it's not really all
that impressive okay you can play Bishop
B3 go after the pawn here but so will
black a rook D5 go after the E5 pawn and
this is um perfectly fine for black so
if if Anand wants a bit more he he can't
really go for Knight captures on C5 so
he goes back Bishop to B1 this is the
only serious attempt known to man to
fight against this line for White Knight
captures on b38 captures and now Bishop
to F5 defending the past Pawn on D3 so
it looks like um
uh very very dangerous at um actually
allow black to get the pawn all the way
to D3 but like I said it is still all
known Theory and Anand plays Pawn to B4
there are many other moves that the
engine is suggesting but I'm pretty sure
we all know that this is the best move
preventing Bishop to C5 and also keeping
around that A5 Square so here we have
Castles by Shakira Rook to E1 and now
Queen to D7 Ponte H3 and now Rook F to
d8 adding more defense to the D3 pawn
pawn to G4 chasing the bishop and now
Bishop to G6 and now comes finally
Bishop to F4 another develops the bishop
and now uh there are uh some moves you
could consider here for example Queen
the C8 is a known move but here we have
the immediate A5 by shark attack who
wants to open up the a file for the rook
and okay Anand captures we have Rook
captures and now as your Rook is hanging
you have to decide what to do you could
capture but if you capture then you
allow the knights to come to C4 b3s also
very very annoying if the queen moves so
here Anand plays Bishop to A2 and this
is uh this has all been played before
but only in one game
and it's a it's a very well known game
Fabiano caruana played it against Danish
Geary in 2015 in Norway chess uh the
game ended in a drawing here uh Aguirre
played a rook back to fade but here yeah
in this game we have Rook captures I
need to the move from the thumbnail by
Mohamed yarov and it's a very very early
early peace sacrifice or rather an
exchange sacrifice this is move 21 so
it's basically 20 moves of known Theory
and then mamidaro prepares this a very
very unpleasant exchange sacrifice and
okay I mean there's nothing to do but to
accept it you're not you're now down a
piece of Rook captures an A2 and Anand
says all right show me show me what you
prepared in the mama Yara plays Queen to
D5 it is the top move recommended by the
engine of course also the queen is now
beautifully centralized so Anand has to
be very very careful now The Rook on A2
is hanging the Knight on F3 is being
pressured so uh what can you do okay
Anand still says Rook A1 show me why why
this is so good and my major plays Ponte
B4 the idea is of course he wants to
weaken the C3 Square he wants to play F6
and after counters captures the bishop
will also help out with the attack
against the the C3 Pawn so Knight to D2
by Anand we have Pawn to F6 and now e
captures an F6 Bishop captures and Rook
to C1 so I'm still on and playing all
the best moves with Rook the f8 now kind
of putting pressure on that Bishop if
the dark Square Bishop moves and the
bush of the back to E3 we have B
captures and C3 B captures and now
uh you could consider a move like H5
here you do have the bishop pair The
Rook nicely uh controls the f file the
queen is beautifully centralized but
mamidaro goes the other way around he
plays Bishop to H4 and now we have Rook
to F1 it's a very unpleasant having the
the rokani one so Rook to F1 and also at
some point Anand knows that if he wants
to survive this he will have to play F4
and that moment is pretty much now uh
mamidaro plays Knight to the E5 and now
anand's pieces are really cramped the
rook's doing nothing Queen not all that
useful the Knight cannot move if you
move the Knight the Knight F3 check uh
will be just uh game over so uh what
Anand does is he plays F4 he kicks away
the Knight even though this does open up
his King to all sorts of uh potential
attacks but okay Knight the C4 attacks
the bishop and the Knight Anand trades
Here and Now plays Pawn to F5 so okay
the bishop is now out of commission for
at least for a while Bishop to F7 and
the now Rook to F4 attack attacking the
queen on C4 so Anand finding all the all
the absolute best moves here and if my
Madera wants to continue pushing this he
has to play Queen to C6 and offer up the
D3 Pawn for example Queen C6 you you
capture on D3 Rook E8 and okay white
should be better but the king and G1 I
mean it's uh it will be very hard to
defend this in a practical to practical
game so instead Queen to D5 by my media
of the he keeps defending the D3 Pawn
but now Anand just plays Rook to D4
attacks the queen and now Queen to a
queen to E5 repairing Queen to G3 with
checks so of course you can just go
after the D3 Pawn so here comes Bishop
to F4 cutting off the queen from
reaching the G3 Square you could also
consider Queen to F3 instead of Bishop
F4 as this allows uh Queen to E2 so here
Queen to E2 putting pressure on the
on the queen and sort of defending the
D3 but not really the idea is basically
if queen or Rook captures um the pawn
here then just Queen to F to check and
it's a very very unpleasant
um it's uh I mean uh you can't survive
this but it's it's very unpleasant so
Anand instead trades Queens captures
captures and now plays Rook to E4 he
goes after the E2 Pawn uh E1 Queen now
my middle will win back his exchange
Rook C capture Sunny one Bishop captures
Rook captures and now as the bishop is
attacking C7 Adam amidara plays Spawn to
C6 and after all this uh uh Madness now
we have uh an end game uh or Bishop star
of opposite color both players uh have a
have a rook uh and Anand is up upon but
can it be done can it be more than a
draw of course Anand will try King F2 we
have Ponte H6 and now Rook the E7 nicely
at um putting pressure on the seventh
rank if the bishop assumes this diagonal
then it could be very unpleasant also
you can put a rook behind the pass Pawn
so here Bishop to D5 now the bishop is
nicely defended and now we have King the
G3
Bishop E5 right away doesn't really do
all that much you just block with Rook
to F7 so King G3 we have rooked F7
offering a rook trade and now Anand just
goes back Rook to E1 with King to H7 and
now Bishop to D6 yeah the bishop now
wants to come to D4 we have rooked the
D7 Bishop to C5 and now Bishop to F7 and
now Rook to E3 preventing any Rook to D3
check IDs and winning the pawn uh Rook
the D5 attacking the bishop and now
Bishop to B6 for the moment Anand
doesn't want to put the bishop on D4
because then C5 is possible so uh maybe
wait with it a little bit longer so here
Bishop back to V6 and now King to G8 now
Mommy darling has to activate the king
somehow King F4 and then further
activates the king and now Rook the B5
attacking the bishop and now Bishop to
D4 and now C5 isn't possible because C5
now runs into rookie five and you've
just blundered your C Pawn uh so instead
uh Rook back to the five by mamajarov
and now Rook the E1 with a very
distinctive plan of Shifting The Rook to
uh to the bra file and uh well harassing
the black king so here's C5 attacking
the bishop Bishop back to E3 and now
Rook to D3 attacking the opponent C3 and
just Rook the C1 so it doesn't seem like
Anand is able to break through and uh
uh the other thing you don't really have
a a way of uh playing C4 the problem is
if you play C4 right away then you've
pretty much settled everything on on the
queen side and now and we'll just start
pushing with H4 let's say you bring the
Rook back to d8 then comes Rook A1 Rook
day seven Bishop D4 and it's a very
unpleasant position that you will have
to defend vigorously until the end so
instead Bishop to B3 a very interesting
uh move by mamidarov saying okay if you
now go after my Pawn then your H3 Pawn
is hanging so here Ponte H4 and now my
major is out of out of moves basically
he has to push C4 which he does but now
Anand has um basically a win uh right
right from from the first move but you
have to see many moves ahead to see why
it's actually winning so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the
winning idea for Anand while I give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that you
can sacrifice this rook and h8 and
promote this Pawn to a queen yes that's
exactly what's going to happen and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is a rooked A1 uh and after I
don't play The Rook to A1 it was in this
position and move 54 that shahren
mamidaro resigned to the game as there
is nothing more to be done here now
there saw everything that will follow
and there's just no surviving this
problem is yes now you can capture on C3
but the problem is it's a forced
variation rookie checking F7 and now
Bishop to C5 that's the star move
threatening mate in one with Rook to f8
as the pawn covers F5 and F6 and G6
sorry E6 and G6 and now you have to move
the g-pawn to create some reading room
for your king and now Rook the f8 check
look at this King G7 only move F6 check
King the H7 only move and now the
spectacular Rook to a shade that that's
the good stuff King characters F7 and
there's no stopping this Pawn from
becoming a queen uh that's just game and
it doesn't help if you don't capture the
C3 Pawn if you move the Rook back to try
and hold this somehow uh just Rook a
seven is perfectly fine you're just not
in time to save the position you play
something like something like Bishop C2
just Bishop D4 you go after the pawn uh
if you try something like Rook to f8 to
try and interpose with with uh something
like Rook to F7 then Bishop the C5 is
very nasty and now what do you play a
problem is if you play Rook F7 then Rook
A8 check and after King stage 7 G5 with
G6 coming this is Unstoppable captures
captures and now there there's no move
you can make here yeah you have to move
the Rook somewhere or play something
just G6 checking H6 and Rook to h8 will
be Checkmate so whatever you do after
Rook day one you are dead lost of course
the mamidaro saw this and a brilliant
brilliant victory for vishwanathan Anand
in uh what I believe is around three of
the of the European Club cup and as you
guys are always very much interested in
the standings or rather uh the what's
the situation in the current top of the
classical Chess World uh this is what's
happening uh Magnus still in first place
um uh he he had that one draw and even
with two wins he is up by only uh 0.9
points then we have the the standard
crew uh Wesley so as he lost one game he
lost Christopher you yesterday was it
was a fine game uh he's down by almost
10 points then come wanna dropped a
little bit ironyan dropped a little bit
Rapport dropped a little bit
mvl dropped a little bit Mama dropped a
little bit and gookish and Arjun uh
finally were able to actually lose the
game after so many games that they have
won so on and um uh we will still remain
ahead of them for quite a while because
we've said that there's like a really
really huge barrier uh once you reach
Duda who is 18 then you have to you know
gain like 15 rating points to actually
to even be considered to enter the top
10 and that's quite a quiet crowd there
Andrew it requires beating a lot of very
very strong players a very uh very often
uh so yeah that's the game and a little
bit of info on the underworld top 23 as
I've shown it here hope you guys enjoyed
that I would like to wish a very happy
birthday to Alessandro it was yesterday
uh but you know just in case you missed
the video and I would like to thank ante
venma eh music Jose Palacio and Chris
Mullen for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day